so in what was completely predictable
news from day one Donald Trump claims to
have fired his third national security
adviser erratic pro-war maniac Chicken
Hawk John Bolton and when I say claims
to have fired I say that because Bolton
is claiming that he wasn't fired but he
actually resigned and Donald Trump only
later announced it as a firing in order
to save face which would not be an
uncommon move for Donald Trump here's
the story first
as per Trump presented obviously on
Twitter were Donner Donald Trump tweeted
yesterday I informed John Bolton last
night that his services are no longer
needed at the White House I disagreed
strongly with many of his suggestions as
did others in the administration and
therefore I asked John for his
resignation which was given to me this
morning I thank John very much for his
service I will be naming a new National
Security Advisor next week now on the
other hand John Bolton's take on it is
different John Bolton tweeting quote I
offered to resign last night and
President Trump said let's talk about it
tomorrow
so this disagreement about whether it
was a firing or a resignation is not an
uncommon one in diplomatic circles and
in administration's that are riddled
with controversy and farcical positions
being held open for long periods of time
and a revolving door cast of characters
but there are close to like a dozen
different and accurate reactions that we
could have to this because there are so
many different kind of layers to the
John Bolton Donald Trump relationship
first obviously from day one just
knowing Trump's personality and knowing
John Bolton's personality it was
completely predictable that the
combination of Trump and Bolton was
never going to work long-term and in
some senses it's a shock that it worked
as long as it did to the extent that it
did and it doesn't appear to have been
working very well secondly Bolton was a
terrible choice on policy from the
get-go so there are ways in which Bolton
out isn't bad per se but as usual with
Donald Trump an empty position can be
bad because it allows Donald Trump to do
whatever the hell he wants with no
very little pushback very often when
Donald Trump gets rid of someone who is
bad they end up being replaced with
someone that is even worse so in that
sense it's kind of a delicate and
complicated situation now number three
is the broader theme here which is the
chaos in the Trump administration at the
highest levels Donald Trump will soon be
if he actually does select someone next
week as he claims that he's going to
Trump will be on his fourth national
security adviser in his first term and
there's also a really good chance that
the position ends up unfilled for a long
period of time which has been another
trend and theme of the Trump
administration so if we were to zoom out
the theme or trend is incompetent people
either in way over their heads or just
terrible people on policy pushed in
positions where they don't get along
with Trump ultimately fired or resign a
constant revolving door of incompetent
unqualified or otherwise terrible people
for jobs and or that being happening in
conjunction with positions just being
empty for long periods of time which is
also a terrible thing in a number of
different ways which we've discussed now
number four maybe the most immediate
question in terms of impact in the short
term which is what does John Bolton's
departure mean in terms of the
possibility of a specific military
engagement or war somewhere on planet
earth because instinct is not incorrect
in that Balt Bolton is a war monger who
very likely could have been pushing
Donald Trump towards war in a lot of
different places and now that Bolton is
gone is Donald Trump less likely to get
involved in certain conflicts maybe but
it's not nearly that simple it could
merely be that Donald Trump will want to
do different military engagements than
John Bolton would have wanted when you
look at the actual areas of conflict and
disagreement between Donald Trump and
John Bolton it's all potentially worse
without Bolton which is scary to say but
maybe not I mean I'm not speaking
rhetoric
here who to negotiate with was something
that Donald Trump and John Bolton didn't
agree with there was a split that
developed between Bolton on one side and
Pompeyo and Trump on the other side when
it comes to who should we be negotiating
with and who should we not be
negotiating with Bolton was skeptical
about Donald Trump's approach to North
Korea which is logical on the one hand
because Donald Trump's approach to North
Korea has been a joke where Trump has
gotten absolutely nothing but thinks
that he's won something major meanwhile
Kim jong-un continues to pull the wool
over Trump's eyes but just because
Bolton disagreed with Trump's terrible
take on North Korea doesn't mean that
Bolton's would have been better Bolton's
might have been less bomb people let's
start getting even more aggressive with
North Korea Bolton said don't pull
troops from Syria which I mean that this
is crazy I would love to get our troops
out of Syria but the way in which Trump
did it completely haphazardly not as
part of any kind of broader plan was
also terrible so like were we better off
with Bolton on Syria or are we better
off without Bolton on Syria I don't know
the answer
disagreements about whether to try to
meet with Iran
so what's completely outrageous about
the situation in which we find ourselves
is that Bolton's ideas on most foreign
policy issues are horribly backwards but
he was fighting against Trump whose
ideas and implementation of those ideas
is often just as backwards or even more
in slightly different ways than John
Bolton represented it it's unclear who
we are worse off with Donald Trump or
Bolton when it comes to national
security which is a stunning 2019 to be
living and I want to be clear I'm not
defending Bolton I think the guy is one
of the worst chicken Hawks who you know
he I actually understand why he avoided
going to Vietnam I would have done the
same thing if I was potentially
draftable at the time but he was talking
about how it was a you know something he
wanted to do even though he believed
that it was lost he was one of the big
advocates for all sorts of military
engagements despite having himself
gotten out of them and again it I don't
I own
stan white one would do that but this is
not the type of guy you want making
national security decisions Bolton was
one of the primary people involved in
the neocon clan to invade Iraq twice
sold the idea to George W Bush I mean
truly truly terrible and yet he at least
understands a few more things than
Donald Trump and may have been slightly
less bad on some issues it's a really
perplexing geopolitical sort of status
quo or circumstance these days who wants
to set the over-under by the way on how
long this position stays open Donald
Trump said next week he would be
selecting his fourth national security
adviser in his first term do we believe
that do we believe that that person is
going to have a fighting chance of
actually being confirmed to the position
I don't know I guess we'll know in about
a week's time let me know what you think